bonjour les amis
je part en couille
il y a sept mois sur twitter un
utilisateur a fait le buzz avec un thread qui comporte à l'heure actuelle plus de 400 tweets oui laissez moi vous donner son nom
ahmedmr
tout a commencé le 7 août dernier
lorsque adam ellis
je vais m'asseoir c'est horrible
à publier le tweet suivant bon mon appartement est actuellement hanté par le fantôme d'un enfant mort et il
essaye de me tuer
je vais tourner toutes les vidéos comme ça ce plan est génial
à ce moment précis le cerveau des humains qui ont lu ce tweet a fait un looping dans la boîte crânienne pour de vrai hein
exactement comme ça parce que le paranormal c'est un truc passionnant on y croit on n'y croit pas mais on a tous envie d'y croire
quand même le même jour et publie un deuxième tweet qui dit il a commencé à apparaître dans mes rêves mais je pense qu'il est
maintenant passé dans le monde réel wooow
Ça commence si bien ! En 2 tweets tout le monde veut savoir la suite c'est incroyable le gars il est trop fort ! Il nous dit que la première fois
qu'il a vu cet enfant c'était lors d'une paralysie du sommeil ce genre de truc qu'on peut avoir la nuit qui fait bien bader
comme les terreurs nocturnes aussi c'est terrifiant c'est horrible il était en paralysie du sommeil et il a vu un enfant
assis dans la chaise qui se trouvait au pied de son lit quoi de mieux pour commencer à vivre un enfer
que cette situation je ne sais pas. Il dessine des bd ce gars et publie d'ailleurs des pages sur instagram et nous
donne ensuite une info importante sur physique de cet enfant à savoir lui manquer une partie du crâne. Une grosse déformation d'un côté du crâne
pour notre plus grand plaisir du coup on a pu voir aux moindres détails
la tête de cet enfant ignoble. L'enfant le fixe et lorsque d'un coup !
Il s'est levé et il s'est rapproché du bord du lit et juste avant qu'il atteigne le bord du lit notre ami adam s'est réveillé en hurlant
ces grands morts et on aurait fait la même alors le jugeait pas ok quelques minutes plus tard adam refait un rêve dans lequel
il est dans une
librairie et il y a une fille qui lui dit "Eh vous avez rencontré dear David" ce à quoi elle répond "Qui ça ? Il est mort" Il apparaît
seulement et minuit
et vous pouvez lui poser deux questions si vous commencez par "Dear david" qui veut dire "cher David" mais n'osez jamais lui poser une troisième
question où ils vous tuera.. Alors là on connaît bien le coup du minuit et nanya "dame blanche, dame blanche, dame blanche" et nanani nanana
Sachez le, toutes les histoires qui commencent par "à
minuit pile" sont fausses ! Elles sont toutes fausses ! Je l'ai fais moi dame blanche ok ?! J'étais en sueur dans mon pyjama mec,  j'ai failli me pisser dessus
Il s'est rien passé ! Après peut-être mon charisme
imposant a fait fuir dame blanche, il faut dire ce qui est. Là nôtre cher adam nous dit qu'il se chier dessus
qu'avoir deux rêves qui parlent de la même chose
effectivement c'est assez flippant. C'est sûrement arrivé déjà pas mal dans le genre d'entre vous quand il y a des cauchemars qui sont reliés les uns aux
autres qui se suivent alors que c'est pas la même nuit ça fait vraiment flipper parce qu'on a l'impression que c'est très réel.
Il nous dis ensuite que plusieurs semaines sont passées sans qu'il est de nouvelles de David. Oh c'est pas plus mal vu sa gueule ! J'suis désolé personne n'a
envie de revoir cette personne bon ! Jusqu'à un jour où david
apparaît de nouveau dans un rêve de Ad'. Dans la même situation
le putain David est assis dans la chaise au pied de son lit et il fixe
Adam. Je sais qu'il y a plein de gens qui font ce genre de rêve. Même moi j'ai des potes qui ont déjà fait ce genre
de rêve où il y a un truc au bout de leur lit qui les fixe et moi même quand j'étais petit j'ai fait ce genre de
rêve donc rien d'alarmant pour le moment. C'est alors qu'Adam se souvient de ce que la fille de la librairie lui avait dit et il lui
demande alors "Dear David comment es-tu mort ?" David répond alors "Un
accident dans un magasin" "Qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans le magasin ?" "Quelqu'un à poussé une étagère sur ma tête"
Ouais, je lui invente une voix ouais. Adam se chie dessus dans son lit et lui demande "Qui a poussé l'étagère ?"
Adam t'es c*n ou quoi elle l'a dit la meuf de la librairie ! 2 pas 3 et toi t'en poses 3 ! Il est c*n ! David ne répond pas, Adam réalise qu'il
venait de lui poser une troisième question ce qui n'était pas censé faire ... Il se réveille alors complètement terrorisé.
Eh ! Franchement on a envie d'y croire à cette histoire c'est génial
A partir de là Adam il a un bon réflexe, il veut savoir si c'est la réalité ou pas cette histoire donc il va enquêter sur google
Il va chercher des trucs à propos d'un enfant qui serait mort dans un accident dans un magasin et Adam déménage dans l'appartement qui
est juste au dessus du sien parce qu'il est plus grand que le sien et il y a personne dedans donc ils se dit "p*tain le
bon mouv' j'y vais". A partir de là il y a 2 mois qui passent sans aucune nouvelle de notre très cher David et son morceau
de crâne au moins donc Adam se dit qu'en fait en déménageant David il a pas réussi à
retrouver Adam alors qu'il fallait juste qu'il regarde à l'étagé au dessus ! Ça me paraît bizarre quand même. Ah ! Mais c'est parce qu'il lui manque un
morceau de crâne
il est moins malin du coup
Pardon, excusez moi excusez moi je n*que le suspens mais j'adorefaire des blagues pour désamorcer puisqu'au fond là j'ai eu très peur j'ai
pas envie de voir David dans mes rêves cette nuit vraiment. Et là ! Il se passe un truc bizarre ! Pendant quatre nuits d'affilée les deux
chats de Adam se mettent devant sa porte d'entrée et regardent quelque chose en dessous comme s'il y avait quelqu'un de l'autre côté. Il est
gentil, il nous partage même une petite vidéo de cette situation qui est un peu glauque quand même
Il est donc quasi sûr que David a réussi à le retrouver. Il aura fallu des mois pour juste monter des marches David quand même
fait un effort. Et à partir de là Adam ne donne plus de nouvelles
pendant 48 heures, bah oui on continue ! Adam n'ayant pas le courage d'ouvrir la porte -il a raison
moi j'appelle la police immédiatement-
Adam décide de prendre 2 photos l'une à travers l'œillère de la porte et l'autre après avoir ouvert la porte et en regardant ces deux
photos il a l'impression de voir sur celle à travers l'œillère quelque chose
*Musique stressante*
Effectivement Adam,
il y a un peu de poussière sur ton œillère, tu devrais la nettoyer légèrement. A partir de là, Adam il reverrouille sa porte
à bâle
il saute dans son lit se chie dessus il a raison et publie une photo de son chat qui attend toujours devant cette porte d'entrée
eeeeet
j'avoue qu'à sa place j'aurais peur ! En plus j'ai des animaux vous savez tout ce qu'ont des chats là, vous savez que des fois nos chats ils font
des faces bizarres et on se dit "mmmh il voit des choses que nous on ne voit pas" T'imagine là quand il fait ça ton chat ?!
C'est horrible ! Et c'est là où ça devient glauque je trouve c'est que Adam il commence à s'habituer à ça et il publie régulièrement des
photos de ses chats qui sont devant sa porte d'entrée et ça arrive tout le temps vers le milieu de la nuit il publie une
autre vidéo où il dit "voilà comme d'hab'
quelques minutes avant minuit comme à chaque fois" genre ça devient normal quoi, les objets ils pourraient bouger
il ferait "ouais c'est normal un fantôme" et c'est là où ça devient flippant ! C'est quand ce qui n'est pas normal devient normal pour le mec parce qu'il se rend plus
compte du truc. Là adam fait alors un move désespéré : il met du putain de sel
devant sa porte d'entrée en mode ça éloigne les mauvais esprits. Quelques jours plus tard Adam il a une trop bonne idée, il télécharge une application
qui, dès qu'il y a du son ça enregistre
voilà je peux pas mieux l'expliquer. Le matin il se lève et il voit que dans l'application il ya trente trois
enregistrements ce qui veut dire que dans la nuit il y a eu 33 fois du bruit chez lui. Il nous dit que la plupart d'entre
eux sont vagues...Il y en a quelques-uns c'est aussi le bruit des voitures qui passent mais il y en a trois qui ont marqué son attention
Rien d'alarmant le deuxième
Ok... Un petit bruit électrique ça peut arriver aussi bon... Avec toute l'électronique qu'on a chez nous c'est totalement envisageable
Et un autre "boom". Rien de ouf, je vous invite à ne pas télécharger ce genre d'application parce que vous allez devenir parano. Il y a vraiment beaucoup de
bruit la nuit surtout si vous avez des animaux chez vous. Faut pas être parano c'est normal moi des fois mec, il y a des trucs qui
tombe ça fait v'la du bruit, c'est toujours soit Natsu soit mes chats. Ce qui est dur dans cette situation c'est de ne pas devenir parano
c'est très important ! Adam part en week-end pour se vider un peu la tête loin de David -il a bien raison-, il achète là bas
un polaroïd pour prendre une petite photo souvenir de ses vacances et en rentrant il décide de faire un tour de son appartement avec cet appareil
Il nous montre les photos il dit "voilà ma porte d'entrée, mon joli mur jaune de l'autre côté mon lit avec la fameuse chaise verte
qu'aime bien David" puis décide d'ouvrir sa porte d'entrée et d'prendre une photo et la photo apparaît complètement noire !... Adam
peut-être fallait-il allumer la lumière ? Ça ne prend pas de photo dans le noir c'est pas ton IPhone ! Et puis là, les trucs étranges
s'enchaînent le fameux son électrique qu'on a écouté tout à l'heure il apparaît toutes les nuits autour de 3 heure sauf qu'au lieu duré 20 secondes
il dure 5 minutes maintenant chaque fois. Un matin il se réveille avec l'impression que tout son appartement tremble comme un petit tremblement de terre
bref, là Adam il commence vraiment à être mal tout le monde lui dit "mec quitte l'endroit arrête tout, arrête tes conneries" sauf qu'Adam il se
dit "bah ouais mais... le truc va peut-être me suivre ça sert à rien" Adam nous dis le 22 août que le vendredi soir il s'est endormit
très très tôt il était très crever sans aucune raison apparente. Il a alors rêvé de David qui le prenait par le bras et
l'emmener dans un vieil entrepôt abandonné. Au réveil, il comprenait pas trop pourquoi il avait pas eu peur de David et pourquoi David avait réussi à
l'emmener là bas alors que ça fait des jours qu'Adam il a peur de lui mais il se dit "Bon ça reste un rêve..
tout est possible dans un rêve on s'en fout" et là il va se doucher et qu'est ce qu'il voit sur son bras ? Il voit une
trace rouge et ça ! Cette mécanique là ! Elle est utilisée dans
beaucoup de films d'horreur, tu rêves d'un truc, il y a un contact physique dans le rêve et au réveil il y a une trace de ce contact physique
qui t'indique qu'il y a donc vraiment eu un truc dans le monde réel. Adam pars bientôt en vacances au Japon, il décide alors d'acheter une
caméra à mettre chez lui pour qu'il puisse checker à distance s'il se passe des trucs bizarres
Il y a une application qui est relier à cette caméra et ça lui enverra une notification s'il y a du mouvement ou du bruit chez lui.
Il reçoit des notifications lui disant qu'il y a du mouvement, dès qu'il regarde c'est ses chats qui passent devant
C'est l'horreur ces caméras l'achetez pas quoi ! Autant jamais le savoir quoi ! Mais un moment ses chats ne passe pas devant ... Alors il regarde la
vidéo, il l'a reregarde et regardez bien la chaise
Elle bouge... Plus tard pareil il reçoit une notification de sa caméra, c'est une vidéo de ses chats il la regarde quand même eeet
il voit son chat sauter sur un truc
invisible alors autant les autres trucs tu fais woaw autant là mec vraiment les chats ils voient des choses quoi, je te jure ils voient
des choses ! Leur cerveau leur envoie un signal d'un truc qui n'existe pas en disant "oh regarde ! Il y a un truc là !" alors qu'il y a rien.
Mais la vidéo
d'après est flippante puisque c'est son putain de chat debout sur son canapé qui regarde dans le vide meeeec!!!
là j'avoue c'est un peu rare ! Il rentre chez lui retrouve ses chats et là ça part en couille sa mère. Il entend du bruit
venir de l'autre côté de sa putain de porte
Il reprend une photo dans l'œillère et cette fois il voit ça ! Ce qu'il pense être une oreille avec juste à côté un oeil
Ahhh...P*tain d'sa mère... Il se passe pas mal de trucs et là Adam rerêve de david et c'est exactement
comme la première fois où il a rêvé de lui. Il est assis dans cette chaise en face de lui, il le
fixe, il sait que c'est un rêve mais il décide de prendre son téléphone qui est dans le lit  avec lui et prendre des photos. Il a fait ça
parce que dans la panique il s'est dit "ça y est David il va me buter et je veux qu'ils aient des preuves dans mon téléphone que les
gens sachent ce qui m'est arrivé" et cette fois David l'atteint
il met son visage juste au dessus du sien, ses yeux deviennent blancs et il dit un truc incompréhensible
puis
il ait debout sur le lit de Adam et Adam se réveille dans la panique sa mère et il y a aucune trace de David
Adam en se réveillant,
va au travail et un moment il se souvient du rêve il se souvient qu'il a pris des photos cette fois dans le
rêve et il décide d'aller voir dans la pellicule de son téléphone est là
god damn it il existe le fils de p*te.
Mes amis c'est la fin de l'histoire
de Adam et de dear David. On sait toujours pas si c'est vrai ou si c'est faux mais on pense que c'est une histoire créée
de toutes pièces
et c'est pas plus mal parce que franchement l'histoire elle est shawmay, pour une fois on a pas envie de niquer le mec parce qu'il a fait un fake
au contraire, on a juste envie de lui dire mec c'est trop bien peu importe que ce soit un fake ou pas on sait qu'il est illustrateur et
cartooniste donc il sait créer des histoires, il a l'habitude de ça il s'agit là d'un bon gros coup de com pour lui en tout
cas ça a marché, ça a fait un buzz total et je trouve que c'est tellement bien géré en plus qu'au moins là je vous fais le débrief
après coup mais quand tu suit l'histoire en direct c'est fantastique bref voilà j'avais juste envie de vous raconter cette petite histoire. N'hésitez pas à aimer
la vidéo si ça vous a plu et peut-être que s'il y a d'autres histoires comme ça un jour qui voit toujours des cris puis
basta le net et bien je vous ferai une vidéo mais en direct pendant que ça se passe
J'espère que vous allez passer une très bonne nuit et si vous venez de mater cette vidéo avant de dormir
bonne chance : poussez toutes chaises se trouvant au bout de votre lit, allez la foutre dans la chambre de votre petite soeur ou petit frère je
vous dis à bientôt merci d'avoir regarder et gros bisous.
sous-titres corrigés par jareb